I have to say, and,
and it would be absurd to me if I lost my relationship with my boyfriend
over politics, I think that would be absurd yet. It's come close.
It's come close at times. Certainly the summer of 2018,
when everything looked like it was blowing up and the Kavanaugh hearings were
happening and we were on separate sides of the,
I thought the counter hearings were a joke, a complete joke.
He thought she was a hero heroin,
a heroin that I thought was insane.
Since you told me that no nothing's off topic and you already brought them up.
So you mentioned, so your, your part, you say partner, I said, partner,
you say partner. That always reminds me. My boyfriend,
boyfriend partner always seems like you're playing tennis boyfriend playing golf
or something. Or he was a boy.
For two years. And now it's been going on 11. He's a partner now. Yeah.
So he moved it to partner he's partner. Fair enough. So, um, no, my husband,
so he's a Bernie guy and obviously, obviously you're not.
And I think that's super interesting. We had dinner one night, the four of us.
And I think it were interesting because.
I get a whole lot of email from people that are breaking up over this
kind of thing.
Right. Talking to marriages.
I have had people email me that they have had divorces or in the midst of a
divorce because of this. You guys can somehow work past that.
I think look because Paul.
All it takes are not the be all end all.
Even though many people might feel that way in,
in this crazy environment and atmosphere that we're living in.
I won't allow it. I simply won't allow it.
And I don't think he will allow it either. I mean, in term,
because we like each other more than that.
Right. But is that generally easier for, from,
do you think someone coming from your perspective than usually the leftist
perspective, we don't have to make this about your boyfriend,
specifically your partner, but you know what I mean?
Like I find people that are coming from it from a more, it's all politics.
Isn't everything perspective can let a lot of stuff go versus, Oh yeah.
A lot of lefties, they think politics is everything, right?
They believe that this thing is everything.
Look I am of that, of that, of that demo.
I will not let politics destroy a relationship and I will not let it destroy a
friendship at all.
I had dinner last night with three friends who are on the right or conservative.
I'm having dinner tomorrow night with three friends who are Democrat and heavily
so-called liberals.
I moved through both worlds and I will never define a friend or not have a
friend based on what their politics are. I simply won't do it. I won't,
disinvite someone based on their politics. It's absurd though.
Of course this has happened.
And it's happened to me through this book and through my podcast,
even though I am not a vocal Trump supporter and I,
what I do is I I've been criticized in the media and I've been criticizing
people who have been losing their minds over Trump.
That gets you disinvited from a lot of stuff. So that'd be.
You mean, you're talking about as well. You didn't even vote for Trump,
but so much of the is related to this. Yeah. It's not enough.
You have to call your face off. You have to call your face off. But anyway,
I have to say, and,
and it would be absurd to me if I lost my relationship with my boyfriend
over politics, I think that would be absurd yet. It's come close.
It's come close at times. Certainly the summer of 2018,
when everything looked like it was blowing up and the Kavanaugh hearings were
happening and we were on separate sides of the aisle.
I thought the council hearings were a joke, a complete joke.
He thought she was a hero heroin,
a heroin that I thought was insane.
I thought it was absolutely insane. And so we did get to a couple of,
you know, whisper screaming arguments. And in pavilions.
You know, it was just nuts.
And I w I could barely drive the car because we're screaming at each other over
this. And I couldn't believe how fast it would come on. It wasn't a slow burn.
It would, it would go one to a hundred and like five seconds.
And you're screaming at each other over this.
You cannot believe I one person at the same time, you know,
you take a deep breath and you realize, what is this about? What is this about?
And I will say, I am the more mature one. I don't say anything anymore.
I just keep it closed. I may look it up and say,
you're the more mature he was saying some things about Bernie, about Trump,
but just like, Oh, well, maybe, you know, so I I'm I'm, uh,
but I can't imagine, uh,
letting politics to fund not only my love life or my friendships. Yeah.
Not going to happen.
So all the people that when they've gone crazy,
one of the guys who help frame some of this for me, do you know, Michael malice,
by any chance, he's an interesting guy. You'd like a lot. He's a,
he's really sort of a, he's even a first, he's not even a libertarian.
He's more of like an end cap. You know, no government, he likes,
he likes kind of chaos. I call them the Willy Wonka politics.
He's just kind of out there really, really interesting thinker,
but he loves the tumble that we're in right now where I think my default is a
little more, if everyone could just calm down a little bit better.
But I would imagine though, also as a writer and generally as a creative person,
it's like, you kind of have to like it a little bit.
If you're gonna be able to get anything done, right.
Like if you were hating this entire thing right now,
do you think you could be creative through?
I actually do hate a lot of it. I really do hit a lot of it. And I,
and it's not, it's not, again, the side that elected Trump that I hate,
I really do hate what's become of the other side of the aisle.
That's really my problem.
And that's what makes me so sad and depresses me all the time is that, uh,
there is this complete absence of,
of connection of wanting to connect and wanting to STEM this divide
that's happening winning to men,
men something. And I do think that the media is at fault.
A huge part of it is a fault.
I don't think brushing bots are there to blame for anything.
The media must be blamed for really sowing the seeds of dis uh, discord.
And the fact that my friends on the left can not speak to somebody
often on the right is a problem.
I think there was some poll taken where 92% of people on the right would have
liberal over 8% of liberals would have a conservative or whatever that is.
I really do see that I see that around LA and I see that around, uh,
the people that I know in New York that, that actually makes me depressed.
That is a depressing thing.
It doesn't make me happy to be alive or to be a writer. Um,
and a lot of what I'm writing right now really has nothing to do with any of
this. I'm writing a novel that said in 1980,
I am writing another novel that's based on an intellectual property.
So I don't know if there's anything about this beard that I necessarily want to
write, write about. I do think that it is kind of a very depressing,
stressful period to a degree I'm a lot older. So I kind of let it go off,
run off me, but you know,
there is stress floating around everywhere. Yeah.
Are you surprised how it's worldwide now that it feels it's not just, you know,
little LA bubble.
It's not just a little American thing that it seems to be everywhere.
Well, look, I was surprised that this book, uh,
was being published in as many countries as it was because it's
nonfiction. And it seems to be specifically about the United States.
And what's been going on in the last five or 10 years here, culturally,
politically to a degree. But, um,
I did two tours of France for this book because they see the same thing kind of
happening. Uh,
cancel culture is rearing its head political correctness to an almost
frightening degree. Um,
as cultural appropriation is starting to also rear its head. Uh,
the me too movement is being weaponized in ways that go against
whatever its initial promise was when it began.
And a lot of people were getting worried. Uh, certainly when I was tour touring,
uh, through Italy of all places,
the same concerns that all of these things that we're talking about here is kind
of sweeping alone, Europe, Belize throughout Europe.
And that nationalism,
another thing is sweeping along Europe as well, which of course drives,
you know, your average liberal, quite insane. He says, yeah,
but look, but, but also, I mean, what is being recorded? I mean,
what is being recorded or reported? I mean, you know, the,
uh, elections in Israel napping the last few days, getting, hear cricket,
if about anything, about anything. Right.
And it seems, I mean,
and the way the headlines were in the New York times and the LA times were,
might be, looks like it instead of like, you know,
decisively saying that this has happened. So I don't know. I mean,
I think we're in a very weird place in terms of how we're getting our
information and how we're getting information from everywhere.
So like you're saying yes, around the world, this,
whatever this might be, yeah. It's happening.
Do you think maybe we're starting to enter a time when we won't need
institutions the way we needed them.
So you mentioned the New York times and CNN before these things,
that core pillars that we all believed in,
and maybe that's part of why younger people are just like, eh, screw all this.
Yes.
And it's almost becoming niche. I'm seeing so much drop away from me.
So much stuff that I used to believe in that I used to watch that I used to read
just dropping away from me because of really most of the time I kind of
bias that I smell and I can't deal with.
So I find a lot of that, uh, just dropping away from me. So, yes.
Do you think it's a risk.
Though, if they all crumble?
Uh, well, interesting. What's the risk? Well, the risk.
Being that if all the institutions crumbled,
the things that sort of link us to something kind of mainstream
that the Overton window will be so blown away,
that we're just going to have factions of people constantly warring over what
is actually true,
because there will be no institutions that are able to wrangle it out. I,
you know,
I do think that's happening and I've started to come to belief that maybe that
is the only alternative, but, but I do think maybe for a democracy to work,
you still need some sort of.
The, you think having the New York times being regulated? No,
I'm just saying the gray lady and our country is really healthy. I don't know.
I don't either. I really don't.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.